muy bien hoy vamos a desmontar un radio
reloj despertador y vamos a ver qué hay
adentro y cómo funciona así que
empecemos hay básicamente cuatro
sistemas que vamos a evaluar el sistema
de energía
el reloj despertador o el reloj en sí y
la estructura superior o la interfase
del aparato y además vamos a observar la
radio así que primero vamos a enfocarnos
en el sistema de energía y bueno ya me
había adelantado y separado este
conector aquí pueden ver la clavija es
por donde viene la energía y tenemos
estos dos cables aquí los cuales se
conectan a lo que se llama transformador
el transformador observan tiene tres
partes importantes el gobernado primario
el bobinado secundario y un núcleo de
hierro el bobinado primario es enrollado
un cierto número de veces después el
bobinado secundario es enrollado - veces
al menos en este transformador en
especial eso significa que es un
transformador reductor lo que quiere
decir que este transformador convierte
en 220 volts
alterna en nueve bolsas de corriente
alterna ya que los componentes en el
reloj despertador requieren voltajes más
bajos y por eso se reduce la energía
ahora bien la manera en la que lo hace
es la siguiente este combinado induce un
flujo de corriente en este otro
combinado y el núcleo de hierro ayuda a
que esto ocurra ya que este bobinado
tiene menos vueltas es un transformador
reductor lo que significa que el voltaje
que sale de esta parte es menor si
tuviera más vueltas entonces estaríamos
hablando de un transformador elevador
ahora bien el núcleo de hierro facilita
este proceso y a esto se le llama
inducción electromagnética es decir este
bobinado induce un flujo de corriente a
este otro bobinado pero bueno después de
energía viaja a través de este cable y
llega al reloj despertador así que
empecemos primero vamos a observar la
cubierta es una cubierta de muy bajo
costo está hecha de plástico modelado
por inyección y vamos a ver por donde
entra la energía y hacia dónde va
las maneras de reducir el costo de esto
es que básicamente utilizan solo un
sujetador y estoy por acá es un tornillo
y bueno entre más tornillos tengas más
fácil será juntar todas las piezas o
desmontar las pero además entre más
tornillos tengas es más costoso porque
cada tornillo requiere un robot o una
persona para ensamblarlo y esto
incrementa el costo por lo tanto entre
menos tornillos utilices reduces más el
costo así que todos estos sujetadores
son moldeados junto con la cubierta aquí
hay un broche bien aquí hay un broche
que hay que presionar para poder sacar
esta etapa y aquí está y está fuerte de
kim es una placa frontal o el bisel
frontal que está hecho de un acrílico
tintado y es de plástico moldeado por
inyección es decir hay dos partes del
molde que se juntan y después se inyecta
el plástico derretido y después sale
esto la razón por la que es plástico
moldeado por inyección es porque se
pueden crear piezas muy precisas y
obtener un acabado limpio y cuando
produces en grandes cantidades
puedes hacerlo
muy bajo y la razón por la cual es
tentado es porque oculta todos los
componentes que tiene adentro excepto
las luces brillantes que se muestran en
el interior ahora bien este es el
interior así que vamos a sacar esta
parte a ver si puedo perfecto aquí esta
es la razón de por qué está todo junto
es porque mantiene un bajo costo una vez
más observa que no tiene piezas
separadas que se tengan que es hablar
este es solo un módulo que se introduce
dentro de esta cubierta así que vamos a
ver la cubierta antes de regresar al
sistema de poder la cubierta está hecha
de plástico moldeado por inyección son
tres partes del molde una parte que va
aquí y otra parte que va aquí y un
núcleo que va justo por acá una de las
maneras en la que se reducen costos es
moldeando los botones con la carcasa hay
un borde alrededor de los botones y ese
borde está donde no hay material así que
permiten al botón bajar pero también hay
unas pestañas que lo mantienen en su
lugar así que todos los botones son
moldeados y cuando presionas el botón
a este pivote que acciona el interruptor
de abajo pero bueno esto lo veremos en
un momento también puedes ver que en la
parte superior hay un espacio para una
batería de 9 voltios es la batería de
respaldo la cual entra deslizándose y
esta pequeña lengüeta la mantiene en su
lugar y la batería se empuja contra
estos dos campos de aquí que son
conectores de batería de muy bajo costo
también puedes observar que no necesita
una cubierta extra en el exterior y de
nuevo esto es para reducir costos la
forma en la que estos se fabrican como
ya dije es que juntan los moldes de
hecho aquí se puede ver una pequeña
parte del plástico que es inyectado la
cual llaman bebedero y se clavan y una
vez que se llena esto se retira y con
todo esto teniendo todas estas partes
moldear las juntas reduces costos porque
no tienes que ensamblar los botones por
separado y este tipo de cosas bien ahora
de nuevo vamos a hablar del poder así
que vamos a retirar esta parte de arriba
vamos a desconectar los soportes que
tienen los botones
ahora vamos a ver se puede quitar
también esto que tengo aquí muy bien y
ahora podemos observar que la energía
entra justo por aquí y si quito esto
puedes ver más claramente que tenemos
cuatro diodos en fila y estos diodos
funcionan como un puente rectificador es
decir van a convertir los 9 voltios de
corriente alterna que entran en
corriente directa la corriente alterna
fluye como una onda senoidal fluye en
ambas direcciones y lo que pasa con
estos diodos es que la convierten y la
cortan así que toman la onda senoidal la
cortan le dan vuelta y por eso ahora va
así sigue un poco rugosa un poco
irregular pero después pasa por estos
capacitores los cuales ayudan a suavizar
esa energía porque todos estos
componentes no quieren que la energía
oscile tanto ellos quieren una energía
directa y suave y consistente y esto es
lo que hacen los capacitores muy bien
ahora qué te parece si vemos un poco el
sistema del reloj
este de aquí es un chip de circuito
integrado que divide el reloj y lo que
hace es tomar una señal de los lados de
cristal el oscilador de cristal es una
pieza de cristal de cuarzo que está
ajustada a una frecuencia específica y
cuando la electricidad pasa a través de
esfuerzo ésta oscila pero oscila a una
cierta frecuencia y produce un voltaje
así que te da una división del tiempo
muy precisa ya menudo esas divisiones de
voltaje pueden ser ajustadas a 60 hertz
o dicho otra manera 60 veces en un
segundo y una vez que tienes todas estas
divisiones lo que necesitas hacer es
separar esas divisiones en minutos y
después en horas y días y mandar la
señal de esas divisiones en minutos y en
horas a la pantalla así que esas
decisiones vienen aquí a través del
cable plano hasta el visualizador de
siete segmentos y el llamado
visualizador de siete segmentos porque
tienes siete diferentes segmentos en
cada una de las piezas y con estos siete
segmentos se muestran los minutos y las
horas
además también hay leds que muestran el
m y el pm
recuerdan significa diodo emisor de luz
y es una manera muy económica y
eficiente de mostrar el tiempo los leds
son montados dentro de esta pequeña
pieza de plástico de aquí y dentro de
eso hay una especie de conducto de luz
que ayudan a esparcir la luz y esto ya
que un led es un punto muy intenso de
luz y está cubierta ayudas bars y la luz
para que cada segmento se vea
completamente lleno y así el led ilumine
todo el segmento ahora en la parte
posterior hay una placa de circuito
impreso esto de aquí y eso básicamente
ayuda a dirigir las señales eléctricas
que vienen del cable plano a cada uno de
los siete segmentos por ejemplo si son
las 6 30am entonces queremos que
solamente ciertos segmentos se iluminen
bien ahora por acá hablemos del puente
tenemos un puente que nos va a servir
para esperar la funcionalidad del
visualizador de siete segmentos este tal
vez esté configurado de una manera
determinada que el puente te permite
transmitir energía
a una parte diferente del visualizador y
por aquí tenemos estos pequeños lunares
blancos y lo que hacen es apoyar el
módulo de siete segmentos estas pequeñas
piezas de plástico se clavan después con
una placa caliente se presionan y esto
las derrite y es así como se sujeta la
bandeja a la placa del circuito impreso
también es una manera muy económica de
sujetar muy bien los objetos y bueno por
acá
tenemos esta parte del reloj y los
botones así que ahora vamos a hablar un
poco acerca de la interfaz nos falta
hablar de 20 fase cuando presionas estos
botones de aquí en acción a estos
pivotes y como puedes ver los pivotes se
flexionan muy bien estos pivotes están
conectados por pequeños separadores y ya
que los separadores son muy delgados se
pueden reflexionar y es justo así como
se flexiona el pivote después como el
pivote descansa sobre la parte superior
del interruptor cuando presionas el
botón del pivote éste se mueve y acciona
el interruptor así que cuando quieres
dormitar en la mañana y lo presionas
el pivote y acciona el botón de dormir
es así más o menos como funciona ahora
por acá puedes observar que esta es una
manera muy ingeniosa de sostener un
montón de diferentes cosas juntas tienes
los pivotes además por acá está el
altavoz y además sostiene la barra de
ferrita la cual tiene alrededor de ella
un bobinado de cobre que funciona como
una antena está antenas para la radio
am/fm las señales vienen de aquí y van a
esta cosa que es una configuración de
cuatro capacitores variables y ayudan a
quitar las frecuencias que no queramos
así que cuando giramos el selector
podemos irnos a la estación 101.1 fm oa
la 530 m o cualquier estación que
queramos porque esto nos ayuda a
seleccionarla y estos capacitores
variables nos ayudan a filtrar las
frecuencias que no queremos ahora
podemos ver por acá estas dos cosas de
aquí las cuales son bobinas inductoras y
pueden ser usadas para auxiliar
una frecuencia en particular si son
acopladas a un capacitor y eso puede ser
muy útil para realizar las funciones de
radio por otra parte por acá tenemos un
chip de radio y un circuito integrado el
cual nos ayuda a de modular oa separar
la música o la señal que tú quieres de
la onda real así que me recuerdan es
amplitud modulada lo que significa que
esa onda cambia en su altura y fm es
frecuencia modulada lo que significa que
la onda cambia su frecuencia en que
tantas veces ocurre para poder insertar
la señal que vamos a escuchar como
sonido de radio lo que hace este chip
básicamente es decodificar eso y dicen
esta es la señal de radio original y
esta es la señal insertada y con eso es
capaz de enviarla al altavoz justo aquí
y bueno antes de que vaya a altavoz pasa
a través de esta resistencia variable
que se conoce también como potenciómetro
y cuando lo giramos cambia la
resistencia en el circuito y además
incrementa
el volumen incrementa o disminuye la
cantidad de energía que corre por estos
cables es decir los cables que van aquí
y hay un bobinado de cobre en un imán y
cuando la energía corre al bobinado de
cobre en el imán ocasiona que vibre
común con nueva piel y eso produce una
onda de presión que interpretamos como
sonido
de hecho así es como funciona también
por acá podemos ver que hay dos
diferentes interruptores uno controla la
sección am o fm y el otro sirve para
seleccionar diferentes funciones como
encender la alarma del reloj o
seleccionar entre el zumbador o la radio
y cosas así
además podemos ver esto de aquí que es
una resistencia y es tan resiste el
flujo de corriente eléctrica y eso puede
ser útil porque ayuda a prevenir que
fluya demasiada energía a ciertos
componentes en la placa y cosas así y
bueno por acá
este es un transistor y este nos ayuda
de la misma manera que nos ayuda un
interruptor y por acá
estos son filtros y ayudan a disminuir
el ruido o la interferencia
electromagnética y por lo tanto al
limpiar la señal lo cual probablemente
se utiliza en el circuito de radio y por
acá atrás podemos ver estas clavijas que
se conectan a la batería
esta es la placa de circuito impreso por
detrás y básicamente es una
capa delgada de cobre que es aplicada a
una placa de fibra de vidrio y después
básicamente usan un proceso de grabado
fotosensible es decir utilizan una luz
brillante y con el proceso de grabado
fotosensible remueven ciertas áreas del
cobre y mantienen otras después usan
algún ácido o algún material para
retirar las áreas que no están
protegidas y así obtener las pistas de
cobre y es que estas pistas de cobre son
básicamente pequeños cables bien
ordenados los cuales son muy planos y
nos permiten conectar todos estos
diferentes componentes en un espacio muy
reducido de manera eficiente así podemos
meter los componentes estos de por aquí
son los componentes los cuales entran a
través del orificio y se sueldan en la
parte posterior y así todo queda
cableado gracias a esto no nos tenemos
que preocupar por un montón de cables
revueltos y cosas que no estén
conectadas correctamente
ahora también puedes ver que hay
diferentes componentes hay componentes
pequeños y también pequeñas resistencias
de montaje superficial y cosas parecidas
pero bueno todo esto al final es un
radio reloj despertador y todo lo que
tiene adentro así que eso es todo por
ahora y espero que lo hayas disfrutado